STANNlS: My brother, Robert Baratheon
had raised the banners of Storm's End,
our ancestral castle,
against the Mad King, Aerys.
Jon Arryn of the Vale
and Eddard Stark of the north stood with him,
and Hoster Tully of the Riverlands would join.
But their lands were far from ours,
Early in the war, Mace Tyrell's
indecisive victory at Ashford
cut Robert off from Storm's End.
lnstead of pursuing Robert
and risking his record,
Mace Tyrell turned east
and laid siege to our home.
His vast army and navy encircled us
and prevented any resupply by land or sea.
lf a wagon tried to reach us, it was burnt.
lf a ship tried to land, it was sunk.
We were locked in Storm's End to starve,
but Robert commanded me to hold the castle
no matter the cost.
He could ill afford to lose his ancient seat
which had never fallen.
While Robert smashed Rhaegar
on the Trident,
my men ate the dogs,
because the horses
had already been devoured.
While the Lannisters sacked King's Landing,
we ate the rats.
lf the smuggler Davos had not slipped
through the Tyrell blockade with his onions,
we'd have eaten our own dead.
But l held the castle
until Lord Eddard remembered us
and marched to lift the siege.
The Tyrells didn't even put up a fight.
And Robert threw a feast
to celebrate Lord Eddard's victory.
l was sent to the royal island
stronghold of Dragonstone
to deal with Viserys and Daenerys,
the last surviving Targaryen children.
Before l arrived, however,
they escaped across the narrow sea.
Robert was furious.
He stripped me of Storm's End
and gave it to that prancing fool, Renly,
my younger brother.
l could keep Dragonstone.
Now, Robert is dead
and a bastard pretender soils my throne
while the realm fills
with schemers and traitors.
But the rightful king is coming for them all.
And l will not stop until l have
scoured this land clean of abomination.
The Baratheons say, "Ours is the fury."
l will show them fury burns.